foreign
all right so I've been listening to you
for the past
um month or so and before that I was
buying real estate but I think you'd
disagree I'm just going to lay out what
I have
um I have 52k in the money market
um of 8 000 in checking
um
and
um I have a credit card debt of 9 000
and a car loan of 21
um my wife her only debt is her car
and we have a house that we owe 426 on
and my three rental properties I have I
a 125 on 126 and 110. but they're all
rented out
so I was going to buy another piece of
real estate but what do you think
I think you should take all that money
in that money market and knock out all
of your debt and leave you with a nice
emergency fund and slow down on all this
real estate investing
until you can get some of it tight off
what's her card at yeah
her cordette
um she's going to be paid off in four
months I'm not sure exactly the number
you don't know what the balance is
no no I just know if she's going to be
done in four months or uh payment is so
it's a couple couple thousand bucks in
yeah yeah okay
yeah so you can write a check today and
be debt free am I understanding you're
right
yeah but then I mean you know I just I
know you're dead against it but I love
having the
um rental properties and having the
money come in but I also understand the
Ramsey Way well here let me how old are
you John
uh 34. okay all right when I was uh 24 I
started buying real estate
and um by the time I was 26 I had four
million dollars worth I was aggressively
buying it
and I was buying really really good
deals I was buying stuff at uh 70 80
cents on the dollar
and so I had good Equity positions
uh some of the property I put mortgages
on and I was renting some of it I had
short-term notes on and I was fixing it
and flipping it
during that time now that was a long
time ago that was back in the 80s okay
during that time was another that that
moment in time there was a real estate
craze real estate was the answer to
everything like it is right now
everybody's talking about real estate
right now everybody in your age group
the 20s and 30s thing it's all over
social media it's all over everything
it's like it's like the thing to talk
about like you're cool if you're doing
real estate right now you know it's you
know what I'm talking about it's
everywhere right uh 100 it was that way
then and in those days we didn't have
social media we didn't have the internet
but we had these things called
infomercials that would run at night and
a guy would sit by the the side of the
sea with the waves crashing in and talk
about how wealthy he was and how he had
bought all this real estate nothing down
and you could buy his tape set for three
thousand dollars on how to do it and
that kind of stuff there was a bunch of
those characters out there
um one of them's got a really nice
Winery now in Napa Del dotto and uh he
was one of the biggest ones uh and uh
makes a great bottle of wine called the
beast side note but anyway the um
but anyway so I was in this group there
was a group of people that started in
each City there was a guy that went
around got a group of people doing
nothing down or low amount down real
estate Real Estate Investors Club of
Nashville and I was in this club with
about 60 people that were doing exactly
what you're doing and that were doing
what I was doing back then
okay and
um they were all buying with as little
money as they could put into it and
making the rent you know collecting the
rents and hoping that was going to pay
the bills and so forth now here's the
reason I tell you that long long drawn
out story
mm-hmm
no one
from that club
30 years later
is rich
none of them okay
except two guys
wow so you think the best and both of
those guys
worked diligently to reverse the process
and get out of debt
I went bankrupt
while I was in that club I lost
everything at 28 years old
and and so did a whole bunch of those
guys as a matter of fact the guy that
wrote the book called nothing down named
Robert Allen went bankrupt
file chapter 11.
okay and so the the proof is in the
pudding when you visit it 10 15 20 30 40
years later you can see okay did this
work didn't work the ones the only ones
that worked for were the ones that
reversed the process and cleared the
debt like George just told you to do so
I I love how aggressive you are I love
that you love real estate I love real
estate I've got a bunch of it to this I
mean after I went broke I made a bunch
of money later and I you know I own
several hundred million dollars of real
estate now I think it's an excellent
investment I like real estate but a
hundred percent of my real estate is
paid for so George I mean I I think
you're right I would stop buying I would
clear the personal debt and I clear my
my mortgages all of them including my
house and you've got the ability to do
this because dude you're a go-getter
you're a guy that gets crap done but if
you don't watch you're gonna out you
know you're gonna outrun your coverage
and um that's what scares me with John
I'm looking at a guy he's he's seeing
his cash flow from three properties I
see a guy who has eight hundred and
twenty thousand dollars in debt and one
misstep could tank him oh yeah one life
situation is all it takes and so I
understand being kind of starry-eyed
with a pile of money going well that
means more real estate I see it as a we
could get out of debt and reduce our
risk and start you end up with all of
these properties paid for in three to
five years including your residence you
can buy another property a year for cash
with a cash flow you'll create by doing
that that's what I did the second time
the second time I got the first one's
really hard you get these three paid off
that's really hard but you get those
three you get pure cash flow from those
no debt at all you can buy another 100
200 000 property pretty quick because
you'll have enough cash it just piles up
it snowballs in the right direction you
know and that cash will snowball for you
if you're not giving it all to the bank
but uh 100 of the time debt equals risk
more debt equals more risk less debt
equals less risk a hundred percent of
the time and that's why all those guys
went broke and they collect well it's
amazing how if you move a little bit
slower right now you can go much faster
later on
oh yeah that's what happens when you get
rid of the debt and you have more cash
flow you're gonna be able to save up and
pay cash for those well what others
perceive as faster but yeah the
percentages shift on you because you
know once I got you know a couple
hundred you know I don't know 500 000
worth of paid for Real Estate I've got I
got serious debt I mean serious cash hit
in the bottom line every month and then
I added some income money to that and I
can reach over and buy another one reach
over and buy another one reach over and
buy another one and that thing gets to
moving and it does it feels like it
accelerates well then one emergency the
HVAC goes out a tenant some tenant
vacancy you're not freaking out yeah you
have a great position yeah I mean like I
don't know if something could happen
like covet where people don't pay their
bills nothing whatever oh wait that
actually happened yeah oh yeah that's it
and then you can evict them legally oh
yeah that uh more moratorium on
evictions yeah
and I'm not going to pay because there's
a moratorium on evictions so good luck
with that landlord
I know but you know
house is paid for and when this is
lifted
you'll be homeless and I'll have a house
so that's what happened to a couple of
them they tried to play shyster and were
like yeah it didn't work out I had one
other come to me that was in a business
that was in a in a I had a script Center
and they came to us and said you know
we're in trouble can you help us
please give us some mercy and we went
yeah we can do that
and uh will you forgive the rent and I'm
like no but I'll uh stop collecting it
for now and you can pay it back later
so I mean we can just pay no payments
for four months and then we'll pay
double payments for four months or
something like that we'll work it out
with you because we're I mean I get
where you are and I don't want you to go
broke I don't want to be the guy calls
you go broke I'd rather you be alive and
and pay me the rent you know so let's
let's work it out I'll let's go no rent
for this month and we'll look at next
month no rent next month okay because we
still got you know we still got you're
still getting fouchied so um as long as
you're getting fouchy doll I'll try to
help you and you had the margin to do
that because you had paid cash
payments you're not desperate you know
and we did have one tenant one time the
the old lady single mom got terminal
cancer
and you know I have the margin to be
compassionate and not charge her and
just turn that house into a Ministry for
a period of time it's a horrible thing
horrible process she went through
and she didn't make it sad into the
story you know but you know but she
didn't have a landlord problem because
her landlord didn't have a mortgage
problem hello see how this works this is
the Ramsey Show